hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
gonna be my Beowulf episode 1 video it's
mostly does the job of starting to build
out the cast of characters and build the
mythology of this show it's gonna take
the first couple of episodes there's
still a couple really big characters
that we don't meet till the second and
third episodes just careful for spoilers
if you haven't seen the episode yet so
what I'm gonna do is explain some of the
like the big core concepts that they
introduced in this like the idea of the
mud-born
and why the lead is buried just a little
bit at the end of the episode there's a
bit of a twist that explains the
relationship of the people in Herat
where this is taking place in the
mud-born
because at first glance you're led to
believe that there's something
supernatural at play when really it's a
wolf in the henhouse situation so let's
just get started so the idea of mud-born
and like the prehistory of the show it's
actually pretty interesting I like the
way they kind of casually slip things in
like the idea of giants or the idea that
there are these like intelligent
creatures born of the dirt of this earth
so just to start in the context of this
world they at least believe that Giants
used to inhabit the land where they are
living before man drove them out they
they don't say exactly how long ago it
was that they drove the Giants out only
that it's been long enough to pass into
myth the mud-born seem a lot more common
and then there are a couple different
types that they talked about during the
episode and and then there's the idea of
like the Grendel type monster which is
an even different type of thing we
learned the end of the episode that
that's more of a skin-changer which is
kind of the twist so that last little
bit is obviously something that it's
gonna take a couple more episodes to
figure out but the basic idea of the
mud-born is is that they're animals that
that people have a certain level of
control over so we open the episode with
the mud-born attack on Beowulf and who
we think is his father which which
actually ends up being a bit of a twist
at the end - but Beowulf shows great
hoaxes finishes off the second monster
but not before his seeming father dies
and Hrothgar rides up to take Beowulf in
now there's no explanation as to like
what Hrothgar and his written you were
doing riding around to the beach maybe
they were hunting the mud-born maybe not
but based on the twist at the end of the
episode which I'll actually I'll just go
ahead and talk about now just make a
little bit easier it turns out that
Beowulf is secretly hrothgar's natural
born son we just we don't know who
Beowulf mother is because he has a why
named Rita in a natural-born son with
her name Slean
who is the heir apparent although not
technically the air because Hrothgar
chose his wife to succeed him this first
episode does a good job of kind of
explaining the the character dynamics so
you have Hrothgar and modern-day who's
died
you have Beowulf his adoptive son who is
secretly is natural born son with a
mystery woman that we don't know about
yet you have Rita hrothgar's wife their
son
Slean in the tease at the end of the
episode before Beowulf was mysteriously
banished for unknown reasons which they
haven't explained yet Hrothgar knows
something crazy is going to happen
Beowulf is going to have to come back to
help his brother but we jump forward to
present day as Beowulf is coming back so
he's he's had all these grand adventures
he and his friend Becca
joke about some of the trouble that they
got into in the previous town he's
already become a man this great warrior
he's come back to town because Hrothgar
is dying he does he doesn't know that
he's already dead but they ride into
erat they find a couple of dead bodies
he references the mud-born like all mud
board must have done this and you
actually you see a mud-born the same
type he killed being used for manual
labor so they're actually pretty common
but but everybody starts staring at
Beowulf Izzy rides in so you get the
sense that whatever the circumstances of
his banishment were they were really bad
but it's one of the big plot points that
isn't completely explained in the first
episode the costume and the set design
is actually pretty amazing like the
Great Hall here it reminds me a lot of a
Rohan from the Lord of the Rings movies
a very similar setting I wouldn't say
that Rohan is exactly Scandinavia this
is a little more historically accurate
we finally meet Celine's character who's
actually a pretty terrible person he is
a pretty big inferiority complex so I'm
wondering if he's going to get some sort
of redemptive arc with bailable usually
usually in a series like this if a
character is presented as being terrible
to other people like this usually
they're either marked for death or they
get some sort of redemption and he does
have a couple moments they try to make
him a little more sympathetic like he's
really upset he didn't save Alvina
himself from the mud-born
but she's like you saved me many times
in the past don't don't worry about it
seriously we meet Bayon who we find out
is the aging Reeve that it's kind of
like the constable he's like the highest
level of authority beneath the Thane and
we find out that the
dane is actually Reda Hrothgar's wife so
obviously even though they're kind of
selling this Slean versus Beowulf
conflict there's a lot of other minor
conflicts going on a lot of politics
happening within the community before
Beowulf ever gets there the presenting
Selene is the big antagonist of the
episode and it next to the mystery
mud-born who it turns out might be the
skin-changer
that's really just misdirection Slean
himself is just someone that has an
inferiority complex like he feels his
father
Hrothgar loved Beowulf more in and
doesn't know that Beowulf is secretly
Hrothgar natural born son although that
would probably only make things worse I
don't think that would make slain loved
Beowulf more you get the sense through
the episode that Slean feels like
Beowulf has come back to take what Slean
thinks is his like take his woman like
oh were you expecting Beowulf no I
wasn't expecting him what's the matter
with you but whatever the drama that
drove Beowulf out that caused him to be
banished in the first place they will
not allow him to see Hrothgar's body in
even even though rita seems kind of like
an antagonist in this scene here where
she's like no absolutely not you can't
see the body and you get the flashback
earlier where she automatically sides
with Slean over Beowulf when to get in
that childhood fight she still seems
fairly level-headed like she is just
trying to be a good leader even if it
means being kind of awful to people
things aren't exactly the same thing as
kings but you get the idea you know
Hrothgar was the leader amongst the
leaders so now his wife has to maintain
that position and a lot of people don't
think that a woman is capable of that in
that time even though you see a lot of
women doing very important tasks like
Alvina is the physician the blacksmith
is female who it seems like is actually
a better fighter than most of the guards
so the stage is set there's some minor
conflict
Beowulf starts meeting some of the other
characters Alvina seems pretty
interesting you know I know like some
there's some twists in the episode that
make her seem a little more sinister
like maybe she's controlling this other
mud-born
she definitely seems like she knows
what's going on it just doesn't say
anything but she's unsure of what it's
going to do so I don't think she's
outright controlling it but I do think
that she has a connection to it either
it knows her or if it is a skin-changer
it's related to her it's a little early
to talk about twists without meeting
some of the other new characters
we move into the banquet scene there's
there's a lot of levity there's a little
bit of comedy
Beowulf's friend breca meets leela the
blacksmith's mother who seems pretty DTF
but then the episode turns in
circumstances lead everyone to believe
that Beowulf has killed bayen but it's
not till later in the episode they
discovered someone else killed bayen
before the mud-born had a chance to so
it's only a coincidence we don't really
know why the mud-born was trying to get
into the Great Hall but the mud-born
chasing Elvina into the woods provides
the opportunity for Beowulf and his
friend to escape they go after her to
try and save her wind up in the giant's
old key which actually kind of reminds
me of Bear a door so I'm wondering what
else we're gonna find in there it seems
like a really big place that they don't
really explore so hopefully we'll go
back there in the future this whole
scene with Elvina and the monster is
just a whole bunch of WTF it almost
treats her like a mother and it's very
clearly trying to protect her when
Beowulf rides in even though Beowulf
doesn't know that Elvina doesn't really
acknowledge that so there's still a lot
of questions about what's going on at
first glance it seems like she wants to
hide the fact that she has a connection
to this thing otherwise she would have
said don't hurt it it's trying to
protect me like she would have told
Beowulf to stop but he chops a couple
fingers off brings them back as proof
that it was the thing that killed ban
but then Alvino rides up and it's like
no no it didn't kill ban it was someone
else someone murdered him someone
stabbed him you get the sense from these
scenes with Rita that she completely
believes what's going on like she's like
okay Beowulf you clearly didn't do all
these terrible things
so whatever the mystery drama that drove
Beowulf away like none of that's been
forgiven but for the moment the more
important thing is finding the wolf in
the henhouse like whoever really did
kill Bayon and as he goes to see
Hrothgar's body and they start flashing
back you actually get to reveal you are
my son but no one else knows that and
then later there's a later flashback
where he says your brother's going to
need you the community is going to need
you and you will return that seems like
it was right before he left he gets
banished then as he's leaving Hrothgar
tells him this so very clearly Hrothgar
knew something was going to happen in
the way they make it seem they make it
seem like his banishment wasn't an
official
as if it were a self-imposed banishment
but it's probably gonna be a couple
episodes before we find that out so
given the way a couple of these
characters are presented like my prime
candidate for the actual murder like the
human murderer of band is VAR here who
they were talking to he doesn't seem
evil but he does seem like a worm tongue
type character someone who has an idea
for the way things should be run and is
trying to protect that it seems like he
supports Rita so even if he did kill
banned it's not that he wants power for
himself like he's not going to then turn
around and kill Rita - the thing that
really sold me on VAR though was like
that last look that he had at Beowulf or
he's like there isn't anything in this
Great Hall that I don't know about there
are no secrets from me and that seemed
pretty genuine so I'm assuming if he
didn't kill Bane he knows who did but
the fun thing about the tease for the
next episode is the idea of skinchangers
so we can talk a little bit more about
the mythology the show as we go along
but let me know in the comments like
what was your favorite moment from this
episode and what do you think is going
on with this mud-born and Elvina like
what is their connection and who do you
think killed bayen do you think that
vara killed bayen so what I'm gonna do
for my next Beowulf video is it's gonna
be a little bit like this too because
it'll be a bunch of new characters so I
just had to explain who they are it's
always fun to try and figure out a big
show but I would say like the most major
change from the original Beowulf poem to
this series is the idea that Beowulf is
secretly Hrothgar son when when like in
the original poem he's just a great hero
from nearby
so the other really big plot point is
finding out who Beowulf smother is
episode 2 is gonna air next Saturday
January 30th on the Esquire network it
starts at 10:00 9:00 central but just in
case you guys haven't seen it I've
already done like a general preview for
the entire season you can click here to
watch that and you can click here for
the official site for the show on the
Esquire network thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys bye
[Music]